lots of people are running for prime
minister but what if piers morgan was
running would the public rather have him
than the rest of the candidates this is
piers morgan's prime ministerial poll
piers morgan for prime minister really
no no he's not running but if you want
to say if he was would you vote we've
been in italy for the last week things
have really changed i would probably go
for sagittarius actually and out of
interest if boris johnson's name was on
that list would you go for him again no
so the next
british prime minister would be
absolutely none of these boris johnson
why the people voted for him yep
not the parliament shouldn't have got
them out i don't think i'll be
supporting uh petersburg i'm supporting
sadja javid wonderful i am the mp for
redditch i'm looking for someone that's
got the integrity honesty restore trust
back to politics secondly have they got
the competence to grip the steering
wheel this is not the time for an
apprenticeship we need someone that can
deliver and get things done saggy's got
that well for now my mind may change as
more information comes out
but i'm gonna go with one two three
it's the first number five for kemi bad
knock well my bet is on richardson is it
possible to say none of the above it is
but we have thrown in piers morgan there
in case you certainly don't want him why
not uh because i'd rather have jeremy
corbyn i think i don't have to vote for
liz truss why because she's so bad that
at the next general election it would
give the left so liz trust is actually a
vote for labour
in your mind mr stanley leading
telegraph columnist who are you
supporting why i'll be supporting tom
toughenham because he represents a clean
start and a return to integrity and
public life piers remains on the ballot
here if you'd like to go for a wild card
his policies include stamping out
wokeness and watching arsenal and
melting snow oh watching us all right
i'll give him for that mr darden who are
you supporting for tory leading mr
dowden
mr dowden pierce morgan for prime
minister mr dowden what about piers
morgan
[Music]
or i do not give it to his peers um well
ps morgan's not an mp so he's not
eligible as far as the others are
concerned it looks to me like they will
simply continue
the disaster that has descended upon
this country so i'm not sure i'd want
any of them as my prime minister from a
labour point of view which one is the
most threatening do you think is there
one that you worry about being elected
absolutely piers morgan well i'd go for
rishi soon i thought he did a brilliant
job through the pandemic although they
did they did go for him afterwards
didn't they risky sooner do you think
he'll sort out the issues on the irish
border
possibly could yeah someone's got to who
of these would you vote for to be the
next prime minister of the united
kingdom uh pierce morgan
three out of three piers unbelievable he
would like his name in the ring what
would you say to pierce morgan as prime
minister uh no i think probably that one
he can rule out congratulations pierce
you are our winner albeit half of people
have voted for you don't live in the uk
and therefore don't count but if we
exclude you it's a dead tie between
sanji javid and kemi baidnock only time
will tell who's going to move into that
famous street behind us